hello everyone I'm Laura Ingram this is
the Ingram angle from New York City
tonight Panic lies and Vengeance oo
that's the focus of tonight's
angle all right it's a Christmas
shopping season here in New York and you
can spend hours looking at the
decorations the lighted trees I did some
of that today in the Rain the decked out
window displays the retailers are trying
their best to entice you to spend some
money but there's one salesman who's
always coming up short because he's
trying to sell what no one's
buying the Investments we're making have
spurred by the inflation reduction act
which I wrote which we passed is going
to communities historically Left Behind
when I took office I vowed i' be
president for all Americans whether you
live in a blue state or a red state
where they live in rural or urban areas
and we're we're delivering on that
promise okay I hate to break it Tim but
the entire country is feeling like a
community Left Behind Joe and as for
Biden claiming to be a president for all
all
Americans Donald Trump and the mager
Republicans represent an extremism that
threatens the very foundations of our
Republic Donald Trump and his Maga
Republicans are determined to spread
anger hate and division this magga
threat is a threat to the brick and
mortar of our Democratic institutions
extreme Maga Republican trying to undo
virtually every bit of progress we've
made they thought demonizing Trump as
Hitler was going to work right they
thought that red backdrop of bid they
thought that inditing Trump four times
was going to work they thought that
throwing his supporters in jail some of
them in solitary confinement for months
that that would work and they thought
being upbeat about the economy just
lying about the economy they thought
that was going to work but none of it
has worked none of it has helped Biden
salaries aren't keeping up with the cost
for groceries gas Insurance your cell
phone bill migrants are everywhere
sleeping everywhere fentel eroses are
soaring no wonder Biden has gotten
weaker and of course Trump has gotten
stronger he's been leading or tied with
Biden since early September today in the
RCP average he's up almost two points
now the more legal hurdles Trump faces
it's amazing the more resilient his poll
numbers seem to be today the DC circuit
though ruled that Trump is not protected
by Presidential immunity against Plains
who claim damages from the January 6
Riot now all of these suits are absurd
they should be dismissed any lawyer who
files them should be sanctioned but it's
all part of the law fair being waged to
take down Trump but again I only bring
this up because the voters are tuning it
out most know that this is process is
unfair and most know that things were
better with the economy with foreign
policy and at the border when Trump was
President so naturally they are in a
complete panic at the White House house
and when you add the disturbing pro-
Hamas anti-israel sentiment among young
people boiling up everywhere well things
are looking pretty Grim for Biden the
war in Israel is top of Mind
particularly a lot of young voters who
say they don't like necessarily the way
that that Joe Biden is um handling this
and handling the relationship with
Israel for many of them they'll be
voting for the first time in their lives
they're going to have to have a
connection to somebody who's 60 years
older than them and you know Gaza is
certainly not helping well remember
Biden faced tight races in the states
with large Arab populations back in 2020
it was in Michigan Arizona Georgia and
for some historical perspective here
1,46 days into Biden's presidency his
approval rating 38% is the lowest of any
president running for reelection since
Jimmy
Carter now this isn't surprising when we
see where Biden is with his once most
reliable constituency
African-Americans his approval numbers
now among black voters have dropped 23%
since the start of his presidency from
86% to
60% meanwhile Trump he's racking up
endorsements including a big one today
from the Ohio Republican
party so what will the Biden team do
next to try to turn this all around they
seem like they've tried everything but
I'm telling you when they panic and
they're panicking look out because
that's when things get dangerous that's
when civil liberties are trampled they
turn the Deep State against Trump in
2016 then in 2020 they got their
billionaire buddy Mark Zuckerberg to
pour almost $400 million into select
Democrat areas to push turnout they work
with social media companies to censor
information that voters could access
they persecuted the January 6 defendants
and they let the BLM ride or skate for
the most part and now special counsel
Jack Smith is even making a data datase
of Trump's followers on X I'm in the
database now all Americans who believe
in the Bill of Rights should remain
really Vigilant the more Biden seems
cornered the worse things may be getting
for all of us but don't be frightened be
courageous and that's the angle hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will will not get it
anywhere
else